как человеку стать предпринимателем если
в найме я 17 лет уехал в Урумчи не знаю
не китайского ни английского у меня все
было классно в найме люди с улицы
буквально с мясного говорили что это не
получится это нереально любой кризис это
время возможностей Моя жена меня наняла
на работу
друзья я хочу напомнить вам что
партнером и спонсором сегодняшнего
выпуска является компания Marine Hans я
хочу вам представить биодобавку с колен
который представляет компания это
экстракт печени глубоководных акул
которые являются природным
антиоксидантом который увеличивает
питание и насыщает клетки организма и
замедляет все процессы старения
оставайтесь молодыми и здоровыми более
подробно вы можете узнать по ссылке
внизу под этим видео
[музыка]
друзья Добрый день мы начинаем пятый
выпуск нашего гемоподкаста это второй
сезон и тема нашего сегодняшнего
подкаста это предпринимательское
мышление чем предприниматели отличаются
от сотрудников наемных которые работают
в найме и как наемному сотруднику стать
предпринимателем Да и вообще не только
наемным сотруднику в целом Я считаю что
даже любому предпринимателю будет
неплохо бы прокачать свои
предпринимательские навыки и
предпринимательское мышление это такой
большая это такая большая тема большой
Пласт вопрос о которых мы сегодня будем
говорить как обычно я Напоминаю что
гемба подкаст во-первых Откуда произошло
это слово слова гемба произошло от
японской технологии кайтинг который
применяется в автомобильной компании
Тойота гемба подразумевается это то
место где что-то произошло какая-то
проблема соответственно начальник должен
поднять свою задницу прийти в то место
посмотреть что произошло и принять там
решение о том как решать эту проблему и
таким образом это слово гемба имеет два
значения Первое это то место где что-то
происходит и второе это то место где
принимается решение Итак
наш формат формат нашего небо подкаста
заключается в том что мы не приглашаем
экспертов чтобы люди не ожидали что
здесь будет выступать только эксперты Мы
приглашаем обычных бизнесменов если
можно так сказать Хотя все они по-своему
необычные Но это бизнесмены которые
кстати маленькая Ремарка не всегда
бизнесмены Мы очень часто привлекаем и
приглашаем людей творческих профессий
тоже это не обязательно только для
бизнесменов Мы приглашаем для того чтобы
Вот в такой неформальной обстановке как
на кухне посидеть пообсужда на разные
темы высказать свои точки зрения
какие-то свои лайфхаки А вы дорогие
зрители чтобы посмотрели и может быть
взяли из этого что-то полезное для себя
Итак у нас по традиции представления
гостей Наверное мы начнем слева направо
Заур тебе слово да всем Добрый день мое
имя Заур Я предприниматель и эксперт по
личному бренду если это так вкратце у
меня агентство маркетинга по развитию
личного бренда плюс свой Youtube канал и
плюс основной проект он в Дубае это
онлайн состязание то есть мы новый
проект создали где-то Через два-три
месяца запустим приложение
от реального мордобоя виртуальный
однозначно
мы планируем составить как бы это громко
не звучало конкуренцию tick tock в
Instagram
там это будет
Зарина А меня зовут Зарина очень рада
оказаться здесь за этим столом и
обсуждать такой интересный нужную тему У
меня три направления по которым я веду
своей деятельность первое последнее семь
лет я строила отдел продаж при
строительстве компании Grohe это
немецкая компания может если кто-то
обращал внимание на логотип сантехники
я строила отдел продаж пяти странах это
Казахстан Узбекистан Таджикистан
Киргизия и Монголия второе направление
последние только два года я начала уже
быть становиться предпринимателями
открыла свой собственный бизнес это
дизайн и комплектация ванных комнат
ванны мне это направление всегда было
интересно и наша миссия нашей компании
сделать так чтобы в каждой квартире была
эргономичная эстетичная ванна которая бы
отражала душу этого хозя на этой
квартиры потому что очень часто люди не
обращают внимание делают красивую
гостиную но не знают
главное это Санузел на самом деле я хочу
показать что санузел Это не просто
санузел а место трансформации потому что
вы утром пробуждаетесь идете
умываетесь вечером Приходите принимаете
душ очищаетесь как ментально физически
поэтому это особенное место и третье
утром туда заходите страшненький
красивый
место трансформации по сути четыре пять
шесть квадратов Да Наедине с собой
находятся думает поэтому это наша миссия
И третье направление которое пришло
совсем недавно это экспертиза по
продажам построение отдела продаж разбор
компании отдела продаж выявление
каких-то узких горлышек И самое главное
точек роста нахождение новых
возможностей которые бы увеличивали
продажи в этой внимание
Классно я еще добавлю Зарина недавно
провела мастер-класс у нас Казин клубе
очень всем понравилось по поводу
построения отдела продаж Так что
обращайтесь за рынок мы ее зовем Зарина
к причем эта кличка за ней закрепилась
после восхождения на Килиманджаро там у
нас было две Зарины одна Зарина т а
вторая Зарина к но они конечно забежали
на гору мы там Пока еле-еле девчата
конечно показали классные Так что вот
такая вот бесстрашная Отважная девчонка
с нами
Меня зовут Гульба Ну я являюсь
основателем сети ресторанов быстрого
питания ланчжоу нам в этом году было
пять лет буквально вот в январе месяце
сейчас у нас 46 действующих и 10
строящихся мы представлены четырех
странах это Таджикистан Узбекистан я еще
являюсь председателем ассоциации
общественного питания поэтому очень
много занимаюсь общественной работой для
развития
отрасли но и миссия нашей компании самое
главное что мы хотим и объединить мир
через любовь к нашему продукту и
планируем открывать 1000 + потому что я
вижу знаю что этот масштабируемый проект
Поэтому наши цели вот такие большие 46
ресторанов и действовать это уже немало
это большая сеть прям Ну да у нас
работает почти 2000 человек Ничего себе
У нас масштабирование произошло за счет
франшизы и 1/3 собственный две трети
франшизы партнерские точки Классно
Классно может по франшизе есть вопросы
тоже обращайтесь
дальше Меня зовут Шарипов бек я владелец
сети утеков шокан мел Вимана наши
проекты Тумар по совместительству блогер
веду свой Youtube канал снимаю про
предпринимателей Ну вот принципе все
классно у нас сегодня такой классный
состав собрался Правда однообразны все
предприниматели все бизнесмены Но что вы
хотите мы сегодня обсуждаем тему
предпринимательское мышление поэтому
Хоть я и сказал что мы не собираем
экспертов но почти эксперты Итак давайте
перейдем к нашему кухням разговорам
кухонным вообще это такое аморфное
понятие предпринимательское мышление
никто не может более толком такого
объяснения что это конкретно такое но в
то же время все об этом говорят и мы
интуитивно понимаем и чувствуем Что Да
оно есть предпринимательское мышление
оно это определённый склад ума
определённые способы мышления и так
далее вот я хотел бы послушать вас Что
вы думаете по этому поводу вообще есть
ли предпринимательское мышление если оно
есть что в чём она заключается как это
на ваш взгляд и как вы в себе ощущаете
это предпринимательское мышление в чём
ваше отличие от других вы же каждый из
вас добились определенных успехов Вот
ваше отличие именно от того окружения
которое вокруг вас было в чем есть можно
я скажу я считаю что предприниматель
первого человека который умеет рисковать
это риск почти каждый день плюс чувства
ответственности и я считаю что умение
работать только на результат
предприниматели успешны он никогда не
делал для того чтобы делать он только
ставит цель и идет только на достижение
своего результата тогда это определенное
мышление и чувство ответственности когда
ты понимаешь что за каждое действие
должен отвечать это очень важно и нужно
понимать предпринимателю что вот наша Да
вот то что мы Деньги зарабатываем мы не
получаем мы не знаем Если ты чего-то не
сделал то идут большие потери постоянные
вот это вот работа над собой и конечно
же постоянно работа в развитии
обязательно предприниматель когда ты
растешь то и команда растет и развитие
нужно никогда не останавливать если вот
эти все качества есть я так думаю можно
становиться предпринимателем
Да я бы добавил еще момент что это
внутреннее состояние Ты должен
чувствовать в себя определенный
потенциал это я в себе всегда чувствовал
и всегда вот какие-то идеи мысли всегда
хотелось что-то реализовать то есть и
чувство
Свободы внутри вот я всегда любил
свободы и найм это прямо определенные
ограничения для предпринимателя и
предприниматели нужно свобода и
чувствовать себя потенциал и действовать
и когда даже говорят там любой кризис
это время возможностей это реально так я
всегда находил возможности даже возьмём
этот кризис скажем так определённый
который с Россией с Украиной Да
произошёл
Я же с Москвы приехал и все планы всё
было у меня построено минимум на 5 лет
на Россию на Москву на развитие в
странах СНГ но когда эта ситуация
произошла меня Максимум неделю когда у
меня какой-то диссонанс возник но потом
я быстро перестроился потому что быстро
принял решение
быстро приехал сюда потому что я понял
что надо ехать что надо в другом месте
развиваться То есть это принятие решений
принятие ответственности риска но и в то
же время видеть возможности и
чувствовать в себе этот потенциал это
очень важно
Я считаю то что
предпринимательское мышление оно как
предназначение у кого-то оно есть а у
кого-то его просто нет Вот мои
подписчики со мной часто спорят О том
что я высказываю такую точку зрения что
не всем должно быть предпринимателем я
действительно так считаю потому что в
одной и той же семье с одним и тем же
ресурсами
вырастают разные дети и вот я тому
пример я рано потерял родителей шесть
лет и мы с моими двоюродными братьями
работали на стройматериалах и у нас были
абсолютно одинаковые условия абсолютно
одинаковые ресурсы кто-то пошёл
предпринимательской дорожки а кто-то
Старший брат у меня там
спортсмен развился да младший брат Он
развивается как больше в найме А мой
родной У меня двое в семье я ему и
младший брат мы выросли в разных семьях
когда ушли наши родители его отдали Вау
в другую семью он там роста я вот у дяди
с тетей и он пошел по дороге
предпринимателей там стал
предпринимателем и я вот всегда говорю о
том что это какое-то предназначение и не
обязательно всем быть предпринимателем
кто-то может быть уникальным хореографом
музыкантом пианистом без разницы А
кому-то вот не хватает Шилов задница
если можно так выразиться которые
постоянно лезет на рожон ему что-то не
хватает постоянно хочется рисковать Хоть
даже есть какие-то блага есть какие-то
какой-то нестабильный вот постепенное
развитие которое присущие больше людям
которые работают нами такой карьерный
постепенный рост там годами а
предприниматели Они же всегда постоянно
что-то хочет куда-то залезть есть один
бизнес открывает второй бизнес и вот у
меня по этому поводу такое мнение
И сейчас я до сих пор не знаю
предприниматель я или нет потому что два
года назад первый слетка это не было у
меня он проходил тогда в Турции в
Анталии Я прилетела туда на тот момент у
меня все было классно в найме я была
сотрудниками иностранной компании Я
пришла туда молодым специалистом
построила отдел продаж набрала команду
Ну развела эти регионы за которые я
отвечала уровень маркетинга уровень
клиентов взаимоотношения все внутри было
классно Круто да это как большая машина
иностранная компания представили на 150
странах у тебя там чёткий процесс и ты в
этом крутишься и у тебя вроде всё хорошо
и тогда у меня уже был небольшой
семейный бизнес который сам по себе вяло
как-то шёл он шел и я на него не
обращала честно говоря особого внимания
сотрудники были предназначены сами себе
в цифрах был бардак и вот когда я пришла
на этот слет там были люди разные с
которыми я общалась помню один мужчина
привел пример когда ты его жена сшила
мягкую игрушку А он ее продал и сейчас у
них большой завод известный там по всему
по всем странам да СНГ
кто-то встретил там своего старого
клиента который с нуля строит дома
продает притом не в Казахстане там в
Германии кто-то Википедии его имя да и
это меня Настолько
у меня во мне зародились Такие
интересные чувства что что-то я не то
делаю Оказывается это ну ты начинаешь
уже себя анализировать и ты понимаешь
что найм это Nine ты там ненадолго Да ты
там успешно но это ты не рискуешь своими
деньгами ты ну не строишь какие-то
процессы по сути ты за какую-то часть
отвечаешь Это очень сильно перестроило
когда мое мышление и за эти два года
сетевой бизнес вырос в 20 раз и я честно
не знаю сама анализирую думаю из-за чего
то ли из-за мышления то ли это везение
непонятно Но тем не менее как бы цифры
так показали что из этого я сделала
вывод для людей всех предпринимателей
что очень важно среда среда в которой вы
находитесь это как игра в большой теннис
когда ты учишься играть если у тебя
сильные противник ты быстрее учишься
этому ты быстрее начинаешь играть то же
самое Мне кажется и в бизнесе когда тебя
окружают сильные люди которые построили
прошли определенный путь и ты за ними
как-то идешь тянешься его неволей
начинаешь подтягиваться Поэтому вот
личного опыта могу сказать что среда -
это прям круто это то что может поднять
и вытолкнуть тебя туда о чём-то мечтать
но в целом смотрите я сразу вспомнил
такую историю вы знаете вот в Украине
есть компания розетка Это тот же
Wildberries Как в России только в
Украине или Amazon в мире розетка в
Украине она доминирует по продажам Так
самое интересное Я дружу с основателем
этой компании его супругой Ириной вы его
приглашали
Ирина так вот слава говорит что жена
началась они работали в найме потом жена
вышла в декретный отпуск и делать нечего
в декретном отпуске она начала продавать
косметику
по интернету и начала продавать
продавать А я говорит занимался в найме
работал работал Через полгода Моя жена
меняла
компании и так далее и дальше Конечно он
дальше сам развивал но факт что они
создали крупнейшую компанию в Украине
вот всё началось просто с того что жена
а в декретном отпуске и делать нечего
боя она продавала эту косметику теперь
вот Это я к тому что где бы вы ни
работали в каком бы найме вы не работали
вам прежде всего надо пробовать
пробовать разные понятно там Или
пробовала вынуждена но Вы пробуете
самостоятельно тестируйте гипотезы это
раз второе Залина классно отметила
значение и влияние среды просто
неоценимо огромное мне понравилось
высказывание одного бизнесмена когда он
сказал каждый раз когда я чувствую что я
умный в своем кругу значит я понимаю что
пора менять окружение
Мне нравится всё время находиться в
кругу не чувствую что я сам умный Ну то
есть когда ты чувствуешь что ты не со
мной в кругу то у тебя есть куда расти А
когда ты в своем кругу сам умный тебе
уже расти значит некуда Оно такое
поэтому среда принципиально важная Я
вообще понимаю что предпринимательское
мышление Это особое отношение к миру
К действиям к людям к деньгам вообще ко
всему например к миру отношение это
всегда насколько я заметил это
позитивные отношения всегда всегда
человек ощущает внутреннее ощущение
контроля что он может что-то менять и он
может добиваться каких-то целей у него
всегда проактивная позиция он понимает
что надо действовать каждый
предприниматель понимает надо
действовать не действует он такого не
понимает дальше каждый предприниматель
для него очень важно ощущение контроля
что он контролирует свою жизнь свои
действия и так далее дальше по отношению
к деньгам каждый предприниматель
насколько я знаю они все деньги
воспринимают как средство достижения
своих целей они не видят в деньгах там
очередные машины дома и так далее Это
для них средства изменения мира средства
достижения своих целей поэтому даже
отношение к деньгам таким таким образом
предпринимательское мышление это такой
набор убеждений и концепции которые
формируют у него в голове определенную
картинку мира и он по-другому смотрит на
этот мир вот условно знаете в
человеческом обществе мы все поделены на
роли и каждый отыгрывает свою роль мы
предприниматели играем свою роль там
чиновника У них своя картина мира они
предприниматели считают коммерсанты
хапуги и так далее
если простого человека спросишь то для
него политики это всегда воры
а для него политики воры Это и так далее
кстати Анекдот такой расскажу недавно
израильская газета провела опрос по
поводу того Чем отличается
политики от воров
не знает
и знаете что выяснилось отличается тем
что политиков выбираем мы а воры
выбирают нас вот и всё больше никакой
разницы разница Только кто кого выбирает
остальное Вот Но это безраиле они так
про политиков говорят то это вот набор
определенных убеждений которые сидят в
голове у каждого предпринимателя о том
что надо рисковать надо действовать и
интересная одна вещь которую я хотел бы
поделиться тоже буквально недавно для
себя понял такую вещь очень много
упоминается что предприниматели должны
быть целеустремленной
Ну целеустремленность показывает как
одно из основных качеств предпринимателя
А я когда размышлял я понял И пришел к
пониманию того что целеустремленность
такого качества вообще нет его надо
уничтожить во всех словарях такого
качества как целеустремленность Нет не
существует природе потому что нету боли
целеустремленного человека чем человеку
когда чем человек которому срочно надо в
туалет
вот смотрите отсюда Вывод что
целеустремленность человеку дает Это не
его качество А ему дает две вещи страх и
страсть
то есть страх что-то что ну страх более
Страх нищеты Страх голода и так далее и
второй страсть когда он что-то любит
таким образом это существует
притягательность целей а не с
целеустремлённость человека если у тебя
цель притягательна то она тебя
заставляет работать
она заставляет тебя делать это не из-за
того что ты вот просто например возьмем
любого целеустремленного человека и
дадим ему нашу цель и скажем дости-
достиг её он её никогда не достигнет
потому что цель для него не
притягательна
всё его целеустремленность пропала
куда-то поэтому целеустремленность Это
можно сказать свойства целей либо это
порождение страха и страсти страсти
имису к чему-то в любви и так далее и
интересно что
предпринимательское мышление это такое
совокупное количество утверждений и
концепций которые у всех у нас сидит в
голове и мы примерно одинаково судим об
этом мире о людях о себе о действиях о
том что правильно что неправильно вот
если
резюмировать то что мы сейчас обсудили
то что я думал и так далее Давайте
теперь поговорим о том вот как Какие три
основных качества предпринимательских
вам позволит добиться успеха вот
конкретно три То есть мы до этого
говорили Какие должны быть у какого-то
аморфного предпринимателя А теперь
конкретно В вашем случае
Я думаю это настойчивость риск и
честность
настойчивость риск и честность Я вообще
это мое мнение а как оно проявилось как
оно проявлялось но я с детства занимался
спортом и первые четыре года у меня не
было вообще никаких результатов я мне
все друзья Всем с теми с кем я
тренировался добивались результаты уже
висели и грамоты и Доска почёта и все
все А у меня не было ни одной медальки
ни одной грамоты и я просто в голове у
меня был такой щелчок пока я не добьюсь
какого-то результата я отсюда не уйду и
вот на протяжении четырех лет пока не
начал добиваться результатов я это дело
не оставил и за собой я замечаю вот по
жизни то что иногда переусердствуешь
настойчивостью уже эта цель не нужна
идет до конца нужно добить чтобы цель
ради цели иногда получается
к этому иногда
четыре года с риском риск но я очень
много в жизни рисковал вот прям
с Я не знаю Давайте на примере
я 17 лет уехал в Урумчи не знаю не
китайского ни английского
Да ну часть денег я собрал на
стройматериалов часть денег мне дядя
месяца
самостоятельно да потом через 4 месяца я
уже там предоставлял услуги
переводчика на китайском рынке я
отправлял товары сюда в Казахстан в
алма-ату Через год я перегорел и поехал
в Шанхай у меня там на месяц если
считать прожиточный минимум был 300
долларов но такси с аэропорта до
общежития стоила 80 долларов и я понимал
то что у меня нет выбора и нужно что-то
делать заходить в какую-то в какие-то
определенные дела Чтобы привлечь
дополнительные средства чтобы у меня
хватило просто на существование в Шанхае
и
я открывал там залы открывал и
общепит в Шанхае когда мне говорили ты
что дурной у тебя незнание ни опыта
ничего И ты полез в общепит и мы открыли
достаточно успешно успешный проект
раскачали я там открывал 6 кальянов
потом все эти закрыл я занимался шерстью
мы с ребятами с Кавказа они мне взяли
как в партнерство я отвечал за китайскую
сторону из Кавказа поставляли шерсть
Шанхай Ну то есть получается у тебя
настойчивость и риск гремучая смесь и
честность Я понял определенный момент
что если ты не этичный и нечестный все
все сломается ты можешь делать строить
неэтичный бизнес но не долгосрочный и я
сейчас вот просто это Кредо по жизни вот
чтобы ты не делал Может у тебя не
получаться может где-то что-то кого-то
подводишь Но если Ты честный перед собой
перед людьми Ну у тебя не будет проблем
их намного меньше становится потому что
на протяжении всего моего жиз
становления как предпринимателей я
совершал много ошибок и как только я
начал брать на себя ответственность и
признавать их и Приходите говорить
извини я понимаю что я ошибся давай
как-нибудь разрулим этот момент я там
либо выплачу тебе и разделю мы тот долг
который эти должен либо каким-то другими
ресурсами я восстановлю ну вот
получается в случае сбеком 3
настойчивость риск и честность Это то
что он считает что сыграло большую роль
в его жизни так у меня наверное я
анализировала часто все идет с детства У
меня отец рано умер и меня очень много
уделил внимание Дедушка и я помню одно
что он не всегда доверял и от того что
он мне доверял у меня вырабатывалось
детство такое качество что я не боялась
принимать решений каких-то и брала на
себя ответственность всегда то есть вот
это Доверие когда
ты никто не говорит это не получится
наоборот получится иди и делай и ты это
в голове всегда держишь Мне кажется это
мне очень сильно по жизни помогала
именно вот наставление моего дедушки но
если говорить про качество но многие
говорят что я целеустремленный человек
хотя вы сейчас сказать что нет такого
слова не знаю как я себя теперь могу
назвать но
всегда если Вижу цель то я должна до
конца довести и довести до ума не
бросить там на полпути не оставить а
найти все средства Чтобы достичь этой
цели Ну и наверное самый Главное то что
со мной произошло в прошлом году вот за
последний год что я поняла Раньше у меня
был очень много страхов страхов
рисковать деньгами брать людей и так
далее и мою жизнь и моё мышление
поменяла одна поездка поездка на
килиманджанджара Я помню в прошлом году
да В это время как раз в феврале мы
поехали на Килиманджаро а купила я
путёвку вообще случай На эмоциях о
Африка прогулка классно ухожу
прогулки
Классно я даже не знала что это там
что-то у меня ждет И чем ближе дата тем
больше у меня страх появляется Я начинаю
читать Изучая все случаи смерти это горе
и хочу вернуть назад деньги мне не
возвращают Потом думаю Ладно поеду что
теперь уже все Назад дороги нет и помню
я прощаюсь домом сыном с мужем и на
глазах слезы и думаю зачем мне эта гора
что я там потеряла
лучше сидела дома заботилась о своей
семье я готовила кушать но что-то мне
делать вообще ну еду все прошло хорошо В
целом это больше страхи Да самое сложное
Наверное был день штурма когда мы
поднимались 12 ночи ночью прям надо было
зачем-то именно ночью нас отправились
к утру должны были подняться на вершину
и я помню там такие моменты когда было
очень холодно на вершине там чуть ли не
минус 25 градусов было и ты идешь и
устал хочешь остановиться но не можешь
остановиться потому что холодно если ты
на одну минуту остановишься начинаешь
очень мерзнуть сильно И тогда нам гиды
говорили просто у них есть такое время
поле поле медленно медленно но Идите к
своей цели даже если устали не можете
главное не останавливайтесь А идите
вперед один шаг второй шаг третий
маленький шаг и по итогу мы не заметили
как мы поднялись на вершину я эту
ситуацию провожу параллель прямую жизнью
Я считаю что в жизни все то же самое в
начале нам цель кажется недостижимая мы
не знаем как ее достичь что для этого
делать но если мы сделаем для композицию
цели Да определим маршрут как мы пойдем
к этой цели найдем людей рядом команду
правильных с кем мы пойдем к или
подготовимся инструменты необходимые
подберем то мы обязательно достигнем
этой цели и Это поездка для меня стала
после нее мне быстрее пошли дела Я стала
быстро принимать людей на работу быстро
увольнять вот это все пошло быстрее
быстрее и я поняла что нужно иногда
выходить из зоны комфорта идти туда где
страшно и я в этом году специально даже
поняла есть даже такие такая книга иди
где Твой страх там твое развитие и в
этом году тоже вот решила новый страх
испытать прыжок с парашюта который
планируется у нас в ближайшее время Да
поездка и э в начале когда озвучивали
эти все поездки я говорил никакой
парашют я жить хочу не надо мне никакой
хорошо А потом чем ближе я понимаю
внутренний голос глицерина Ты что
скажешь себе что ты струсила не пойдёшь
что ли Тебе страшно Ты чего спросишь и я
[музыка]
а у Зарины качество не риски брать Дело
в том что она с детства росла у дедушки
дедушка ей доверял Доверие всегда
вызывает уверенность уверенность
уверенность вызывает смелость но
смелость и уверенность в достижении того
что она хочет
но то есть она не не достигала целей
благодаря страху она благодаря достигала
цели благодаря своим выбору своим
желаниям В твоем случае ты это делал
благодаря страху Зарина недавно
научилась достигать цели благодаря
страху Вот она теперь поняла что
оказывается страх тоже может позитивно
влиять страх как раз порождает Стимул
Стимул это вот то что в Древней Греции
такая была острая палка БК чтобы он
тащил повозку либо плуг и смысл стимула
убегать от боли от страха вот Зарина
освоила новую технологию достижения цели
Это теперь
убегать от страха То есть можно сказать
как помощник достижения целей
[музыка]
умение рисковать я много лет была женой
успешного мужа мужья никогда не работала
в найме и 2017 году когда у меня было
кафе с партнером и когда меня обвинили
они порядочность Я из него вышла и в мае
Мы приняли решение переехать из Астаны в
июне Мы продали в Юле переехали там как
раз большой кассовый разрыв куча Долгов
муж не работает и тогда в принципе
наверное вот этот самый здесь тогда бы я
принимала решение э снять в аренду и
купить премиальное Жильё и мы решили
всё-таки купить э у вернее снять в
аренду квартиру и оставшиеся деньги там
пустить именно в бизнес тогда я по сути
своей мы Представьте 20 лет жили очень
хорошо и никогда не жили с на съёмной
квартире мы просто ушли там вниз и пошли
рисковать тогда у меня не было опыта
практически в бизнесе в найме абсолютно
никакого не было Вот это вот именно
умение рисковать мне очень сильно
помоглох
нет тогда в тот момент многие наверное
страх нищеты Почему Потому что мы
привыкли жить хорошо и тут получается ты
немного чего не можешь позволить а
тратишь ты гораздо больше чем ты
зарабатываешь это вот состояние было
года на последние три года почему мы
вышли из этой зоны комфорта нужно было
что-то делать потому что там 700
квадратов капель всё хорошо А по факту
ты не тянешь Этот
второй - Это наверное моя безусловно
Вера я когда решила что я буду это
делать то разве что мне по-моему даже
люди с улицы буквально смысл слова
говорили что это не получится это
нереально А я по-своему шла и делала
себе Вот наверное та интуиция которая
мне всё время помогает сейчас даже Кто
бы что не сказал я делала то что я
считаю нужным мне никакие правила знаний
в бизнесе то что меня абсолютно не
волнует я делаю что я чувствую моменте
это делаю всё И вот это мне очень сильно
двигает помогает Почему Потому что
многие вещи я делаю против правила чётко
понимаю очень ресторанов построены так
Где Когда Ну у нас же есть же аналитика
да И когда например мы третий ресторан
открывали я потом через год поняла что
он Априори не должен был быть успешным
там не было никаких А я просто зашла
сказала все здесь открываем если бы
сейчас мои знания тогда я бы там это не
сделала это сегодня он один из успешных
ресторанов поэтому безусловно вера в то
что ты делаешь И когда ты не
сомневаешься это очень сильно тебе
помогает Ну и третье качество которое
Вот я считаю скорость
умения принимать решение быстро
действовать и сейчас даже я команду учу
если мы приняли решение когда нужно
сделать Вчера всё быстро в моменте
сделали пошли И решение принимать здесь
же сейчас же у меня никогда не бывает
что там даже час о чём-то
пришел вопрос пришел ответ пошли делать
И вот эти качества мне на сегодняшний
день помогли и Да у меня не было опыта в
найме абсолютно я вообще в принципе
работы не было А что такое бизнес я
вообще не понимала честно говорю почему
Потому что слово делегирование первый
раз услышала в 2018 году в апреле месяце
чтоб вы понимали уровень моего знаний
как Бизнесмен и в роду у меня вообще
никого нет у меня учителя инженера врачи
Вот такие все я вот первый вообще по
папину по моему налене которую вот в эту
сторону пошел и я в принципе да я очень
довольна довольна тем что я сегодня
делаю Почему Как вы сказали ты
предпринимателем созидает он что-то
делает большое глобально это ты первое
время какие-то потребности закрываешь
потом когда потребности закрыл Ты
понимаешь блин всё надо уже что-то идти
дальше что-то делать большое и уже там
история Идёт уже совсем не про деньги
это люди это образование обучение
благотворительность какая-то большая
Мисс ещё что-то хочешь чувство
вкладываешься вкладываешься и вот это
тебя бесконечного вдохновляет наверное
вот это вот когда мне говорят там как вы
работаете И откуда столько энергии
Наверное от всего того что ты делаешь
Что ты хочешь Я сегодня исключительно
делаю только то что я хочу я в обществе
там только где мне нравится и вот это
вот свобода которую я скажем так
много-много лет к ней Шла я ее прям
берегу обожаю я понимаю что вот это вот
тот Поток информации который мне наверно
сверху идет у меня и двигает и вот это
вот Доверие себе очень сильно Мне
например сегодня помогает Почему Потому
что ну не быть наверное вот этого
доверия этого всего не получилось бы
когда тебе начинает люди советовать надо
так надо так надо так А ты понимаешь что
нет с этим не согласен Я делаю как я
хочу вот это мне сильно помогло
в таком случае у тебя получилось рис
во-вторых уверенность вера в то что ты
делаешь и третья скорость основная так
классно Так кстати хороший пример
Обратите внимание в восемнадцатом году
только первый раз услышала слово
делегирование вообще ни сном ни духом не
знала про бизнес если Зарина она
наполовину знала процессы потому что она
работала всё-таки в организации продаж
крупные немецкие компании то в случае
чтобы оно вообще ничего не знала это да
Это я к тому что вот может быть
домохозяйки которые нас смотрят не
думайте что у нас нету шансов вот вам
пример шансов Все в ваших руках
но касаемо моего мнения считаю в первую
очередь предприниматель должен быть
энергичным вот что-то нет что тебе три
вещи Что тебе помогло Но вот мне это и
помогло Моя энергичность в первую
очередь и плюс предприимчивость Я всегда
предпринимал что-то но начиная с
энергичности А здесь с собой энергичным
всегда чего-то хотел как раз шило где-то
у меня было не могу сидеть на месте всё
время да и в школе и там в университете
и в работе я в начале работал Я инженер
проектировщик строительном образования
работал
[музыка]
там постоянное движение то есть Моя
энергичность мне всегда помогала
во-первых во-вторых именно
предприимчивость как я сказал и всегда
что-то даже в работе что-то интересное
находил А вот так если что-то сделать
вот так то есть постоянно но я родился в
Чечне и чеченец по национальности и там
очень много условностей Как вы тоже
сказали Вот не надо то что это подумаешь
что тут скажет эти условности меня
всегда тормозили и мешали развиваться и
поэтому даже я уехал оттуда потому что
они видишь потенциала развития для себя
и уехал в Москву И там было бы больше
Свободы больше возможностей Я
максимально это использовал и третий
момент это упорство то есть и как даже
Улугбек сказал я тоже с детства
занимаюсь и постоянное Преодоление себя
физических качеств ментальных Да вот
постоянно борьба в первую очередь самим
собой соперником То есть я всегда в
тренировках это находил поэтому именно
благодаря тренировкам я стал более
упорным дисциплинирован Да и целена
целеустремлённых
потому что я если я там вижу например
там каких-то соревнованиях надо выиграть
а по-любому к этому готовился и прям
четко шел к этому но опять-таки вопрос
больше к мотивации Да насколько это
интересно смотрите мы всех послушали
резюмируя скажу вот оба раза вы
попытались использовать слово
целеустремленность я ещё раз попытаюсь
объяснить смотрите существует Стимул
существует мотивация Стимул всегда
мощнее чем мотивация Стимул это всегда
убегать от чего-то мотивация - это
бежать К чему-то
условно пример за вами поднялся Медведь
вы бежите на максимальной возможной
скорости выжимаете себя Всё потому что
Медведь бежит Но после того как мы
пробежали 2 км смотрит Медведь за вами
дальше не бежит у вас стимул
то есть для того чтобы дальше бежать вам
уже должна быть мотивация А зачем потому
что мотивация отвечает на вопрос Зачем
если представить как снаряд вот
Представьте или как ракета Стимул это
пинок который выпиливает Вас а потом
должен включиться ваш двигатель ваш
двигатель он вас тащит всю жизнь а
Стимул он дает короткий но очень сильный
пинок вот Стимул Вы должны воспринимать
как пинок Поэтому если хотите себя с
места выпнуть вот мне часто спрашивают
где найти мотивацию Ребята сходу вы
мотивацию не найдете вот в случае с
гульбаном Она сначала начала рисковать
она боялась попасть в нищету потому что
она знала что такого хорошо жить после
этого она боялась без ничего когда сразу
боялась попасть в нищету и начала
работать как угорелая и только когда она
достигла определенных высот она начала
задумываться о зачем это и у него
появилась благотворительность миссия
желание менять общество и так далее так
было эволюция это тот случай когда
Сначала она дала себе пинок до
определенного уровня прилетела дальше
включился ее собственный двигатель и она
полетела дальше и в этом плане когда
меня спрашивают вот у меня нет мотивации
Как начать бизнес что делать и так далее
вот вам пример Зарины классный пример
выпьте из себя из ситуации поставьте
себе угрозу человек от страха двигается
гораздо быстрее в состоянии страха у
человека острее четче реакция он четко
знает куда идет Я приводил пример когда
человеку срочно надо в туалет он четко
знает что делать Нет более
целеустремлённого человека чем человек
который хочет в туалет Почему Потому что
у него страх отделаться
поэтому он найдет туалет он бежит он
четко его ничего не мешает ничего не
отвлекает никакие социальные сети
YouTube и Instagram его не могут
спустить
в случае Зариной вот Зарина показала что
страх
это реально очень сильный двигатель
поэтому Выйдите из зоны комфорта
поставьте под угрозу свою существование
Если вы Лежите на диване и говорите у
вас нет мотивации она и не будет
Встаньте с дивана вот уедьте как Улугбек
куда-нибудь Шанхай с тремя 100 долларами
в кармане вы увидите как у вас проснулся
стены вы будете как каждый день
чувствовать как у вас очко Джим будет
Было такое Было что я буду кушать где
буду ночевать что делать
автоматически научитесь адаптироваться
приспосабливаться смотреть на настроение
других людей думать о том что другие
люди хотят у вас никогда не возникнут в
голову в голове мысль что-то у меня
мотивации нет мотивация нет Когда у вас
все благополучно
Когда вы основные стимулы прошли условно
запал закончился Стимул а двигатель свой
не включился Поэтому вот яркие хороший
пример Сегодня у нас гости классно прям
как на подбор У всех разные истории Но я
прям на вас смотрю и мне я просто кайфую
потому что разные история вы даёте одну
такую картинку хорошую Давайте теперь
поговорим о том что вот смотрите нас
наверняка смотрят очень много домохозяек
людей которые работают в найме и так
далее А вот как человеку стать
предпринимателем если он в найме то есть
есть один подход надо говорить сразу
нырять и там поплывёшь А есть другой
подход сразу не нырять не надо Надо
сначала Ну как бы готовиться кто что
думает по этому поводу
Ну давайте
я считаю то что если человек работает в
найме Первое он должен предупредить на
того на кого он работает что он
параллельно будет чем-то заниматься
потому что это уже все равно будет
расфокус то что может что-то тестить но
ни в коем случае сразу бросать то что
Откуда приходит тебе деньги и заниматься
предпринимательством это такая опасный
выбор если у тебя нету другой источника
дохода и параллельно сработает тестить И
постепенно тестить ниши Какая стрельнет
постепенно направлять туда фокус там 5-6
Но это на самом деле сегодня это сделать
очень легко подобрал 5 картинок запустил
таргер По 10 долларов посмотрел что
больше всего приносит заявок все вот
смотри здесь я вмешаюсь в каком плане
вы знаете лучший способ узнать у врача
правда
это не слушать то что он говорит что
нужно делать вам как Пациенту А лучше
спросить у него Если бы я был вашим
сыном
как бы вы лечили меня чтобы вы прописали
и тогда врач очень часто меняет или или
когда вы говорите Если бы вы были бы на
моем месте Вы бы как лечились и тогда
очень часто врач говорит Ну понятно по
протоколу я обязан прописать вот эти
лекарства но и сам бы я
принял бы вот это и остальное не брал
потому что здесь может быть побочка
может быть это иначе ты тут начинает
вылезать всплывать то что он реально для
себя это сделал в твоем случае так как
мы услышали историю что ты страшно
рискуешь А здесь нам говоришь о том что
рисковать не надо
а чтобы ты сделал Но если бы я был бы на
месте того Ну я во-первых не пошел Ну
хорошо
я бы оставил Пошел бы рисковал
что исследовал доказать а люди же разные
но вот сейчас кто-нибудь послушает и
скажет вот они сказали надо рисковать
всё бросили Пошли у них не получилось
потом скажут Ты что ну в твоём случае я
не пошёл рисковать в моём случае да это
постоянно
Да вот мы например сидели здесь ой в
Шанхай говорю в Казахстане когда мы
точки Начали открывать приехал Дима
Портнягин на просто пике своей
популярности снимает у нас выпуск и у
нас там полторы тысячи заявок с 10 стран
на франшизу и выпуске он говорит хотите
открыться в Москве мы говорим конечно
хотим приезжаем туда начинаем переговоры
и в итоге мы не договорились И я говорю
своему партнёру типа ну надо открываться
мы берём деньги в долг влезаем в долги и
открываемся на непонятном рынке не
сделать никакой анализ на Патриарших
прудах рядом с сосульством Да там просто
на тусовочном месте открываем бутик
одежды казахстанским брендом запускаем
туда пули мы 250.000 долларов и
Но что дало нам вот такой
Безумный Шаг в итоге у нас после боя с
макгрегором Хабиб он первый в мире и
смотрит с кем коллабудем и первый в мире
бренд как схема сделал колам на тот
момент его пик его популярности Обогнал
там все запросы в соцсетях
и на этом пике он выставляет нас и
рекламирует Мы конечно одели там всю
он сам с Махачкалы Столько людей
приехала Мы ходили все даем постоянно
составлял вот что принесло потом вот
такие какие-то безумные круто смотрите
если
постепенно предупредить работодатель
постепенно тестировать гипотезы и не
спешить уходить в свободный бизнес но
лично он сам бы сразу все бросил бы и
пошёл заниматься
не советую кстати вот Возьмите себе этот
лайфхак с врачами работает и я вам
продемонстрирую как он работает в жизни
у меня наоборот Все вот на 180 градусов
Наоборот я все того наверное по природе
Я женщина я не могу так взять всё
рисковать все деньги вложить
Я никогда наверное не рисковала так
сильно э-э и по знаку Зодиака за то что
весы У меня есть привычка всё взвешивать
анализировать
Ну в общем у меня путь другой свой Да он
он в основном строился на том на
тщательном анализе и подготовке почвы То
есть если уходить с найма Ну во-первых
что мне дал нам Я помню Да очень большие
сильные знания то есть структурность
процесса даже сейчас вот Анализируя
отделы продаж в компании я понимаю что у
90 процентов казахстанских компаний нет
техпроцессов которые делают по миру и я
понимаю что я колоссальные знания
получила в этой компании за что очень
благодарна
компании Grohe но это мне дает
знания которые я могу очень быстро может
быть если бы я может быть я дольше шла
Да Сейчас у меня есть эти знания которые
я могу очень быстро монетизировать и и
также принести какую-то пользу общества
Поэтому у всех свой путь Я не рискую Я
прежде чем рисковать просчитываю
планирую пробую А теперь чтобы ты
посоветовала чтобы я посоветовала
очень много людей в начале очень много
думают много чего вот мне очень
понравилось ваше выражение что голова
Это не процессор для хранения данных а
не сервер для хранения данных а
процессор для принятия правильных
решений очень много людей А я знаю
которые много чего знают но боятся выйти
из этой коробочки и сделать шаг А вдруг
не получится а вдруг не то и это их
сковывает и по сути Я всегда говорю А
представь если тебе было там 60 уже 70
лет и ты сидишь и думаешь Да мне было 30
я не рискнула не попробовала А сейчас я
вот время зря Ушло да Вот чтобы так люди
не думали лучше рискуете и выходить из
зоны комфорта
про риск случай у нас был когда был год
молодежи мне давно сидела мысль
встретиться с президентом просто
хотелось встретиться с президентом и
либо события Так притянулись нам звонят
и говорят не хотите ли вы вас выбрали
как один успешных кейсов на год молодежи
и будут 5 стендов и вы будете один одним
из них нас сюда позвали и две недели нас
гоняли и готовили прямо по сценарию что
мы должны говорить нас проверяли нас
гоняли код каждую Каждое слово каждую
буковку мы там перед министрами
отчитывались рассказывали как мы будем
говорить что мы будем говорить и Шаг
вправо шаг влево и момент когда была
сама презентация вот первым президентом
он обошел четыре стенда и подходит к нам
и Зато из-за волнения из-за переживания
это все чтобы идти Прям по инструкции
Сзади стоит а п стоят министры стоит все
стоят и нужда напишет подходит нашему
стенду и мы рассказываем Кто мы такие
чем мы занимаемся и он такой подходит
не хотите ли вы стать нашим амбассадором
не было вообще мы это не прописывали нам
не разрешали А мы заранее до этого
спрашивали у Ап у меня там был
мой сокурки научились Шанхай он нам
скинул размер его мы заранее подготовили
два костюма и он такой говорит Да
конечно я не против
и все прикиньте вот такой необдуманный
шаг но естественно После этого мы
разорвали там все соцсети там кто Только
нас не публиковал то что молодой бренд и
амбассадором бренда выступил президент
страны это круто Это хорошая история это
хорошая история как раз это как раз мы
поговорим об этом дальше о том как
разорвать свою ментальную тюрьму который
большинство людей принимает к сожалению
я тут согласна с улугбеком Я бы тоже не
рисковала я сначала наверное определенно
подготовилась Поняла бы потому что я
считаю что предпринимательское мышление
это действительно определенные люди
которые умеют так думать почему потому
что у меня муж пытался быть
предпринимателем не смог У меня подруга
рядом со мной была четыре года она тоже
не смогла это всё-таки определенные
мышление и тут нужно понимать если в
тебе эти качества поэтому я бы сначала
бы подготовилась бы подняла бы нужно или
нет Э и только потом наверное уходила бы
с нами Потому что риск - это достаточно
большой но что касается меня Да я могу
его до хоть куда-то мне сейчас хочется
предложить
с точки зрения себя рискую всегда
но давайте я на личном примере и реально
то что думаю скажу я считаю нужно
рисковать но рисковать как вот например
возьмём меня Я до 30 лет жил в Чечне Я
нормально работал у меня аптечный бизнес
был Всё нормально это было но мне
хотелось большего и я продал бизнес ушел
с работы переехал прям с нуля в Москву и
начинал с нуля и не было у меня были
родственники нас принципиально к ним не
ходил То есть я сам двигался сам Просто
я понимал один момент что вернуться я
всегда успею то есть Любой человек
который Эксперт в своем деле он если
даже работает в найме там будет то
продажник маркетолог он должен понимать
что вернуться маркетологом стать опять
всегда сможет Но если он хочет Если он
чувствует что он может то нужно Ну
сперва нужно изучить сферу потому что
например маркетологов в найме он в найме
всё безопасно но бизнес - это совсем
другое нужно изучить что такое
бизнес-процессы риски всё взвесить
как-то Ну сделать шаг потому что он
опять стать маркетологом всегда успеем
поэтому я за риски
вот мы получили различные виды Советов
лайфхаков Кстати очень интересно вас
слушать
чтобы я сказал резюмирую резюмирую я бы
сказал бы так ребята те кто работает в
найме
у вас также есть возможность быть
бизнесменом находясь на своем рабочем
месте не надо делать бизнес на стороне
Просто Обратите внимание на такие
вопросы в вашей компании Откуда приходят
деньги в вашу компанию что ваша компания
продает какую ценность для потребителя
создает Кто является вашим поставщиком
Кому вы поставляете то есть Посмотрите
на свое рабочее место как бизнесмен как
собственник предприятия Многие думают Я
прихожу на наемную работу и поэтому они
специализируются только в своей
специальности вот он маркетолог он
специализируется только маркетинге
а вы на своем рабочем месте станете
бизнесменом вы начнете думать А где мы
материалы берем А где мы закупаем А кто
наши поставщики А кто наши основные
клиенты А кто производит А какую
технологию мы используем и так далее
начните думать как собственник
предприятия Представьте что вы
собственник даже если вы работаете в
уборщицей Представьте что вы собственник
предприятия сразу изменится у вас
мышление вы по-другому начнете Смотреть
на свои функциональные обязанности на
свою работу на своих соседей коллег
всё предприятие на клиентов и так далее
И что самое интересное произойдёт
Если вы начнете думать как собственник
предприятия как бизнесмен то у вас
появится очень много идей как лучше
сделать свою работу это раз во-вторых Вы
невольно начнете интересоваться другими
подразделениями значит вы будете знать
большую картинку 2 в-третьих вы невольно
захотите брать больше ответственности и
это приведет к тому что вы научитесь
быть предпринимателем за чужой счет
практически вам платят зарплату пустили
вас в лабораторию и ты ходишь в
лаборатории у всех может спрашивать А ты
что делаешь А ты что делаешь А ты что
делаешь А тебе еще зарплату А ты в
результате изучаешь всё как внутри
устроено и самое интересное Когда вы
начнете Мыслить как предприниматель У
вас откроется две дорожки первое Вы
можете со временем уйти уже и
самостоятельно открывать бизнес потому
что вы знаете все процессы Поверьте мне
во все компании все процессы почти
одинаковые
либо А это случится скорее всего ваш
собственник вас заметит И вам предложат
должен свыше и у вас Карьерная лестница
у вас карьерных взлет будет гораздо
гораздо быстрее мы ведь как собственники
как предприниматели заметьте Мы всегда
ценим сотрудников которые приходят к нам
не с проблемами а с решением и непростым
решением его узким решением которого
удовлетворяет только его отдел А с
решением которое приносит благо всему
предприятию соответственно только такой
сотрудник У меня появляется у меня
возникает желание его поднять сразу же
возникает желание поднять потому что мы
все бизнесмены у нас такой склад ума Мы
хотим нам самим чтобы Расти нам нужно
чтобы снизу нас кто-то подпирал поэтому
мой совет для тех кто в найме и
поступайте Именно таким образом
работаете на том же месте где вы
работаете просто начните мыслить думать
и анализировать как собственник и вы
увидите как результаты не заставят Себя
ждать можно вопрос а
Это должен быть склад ума такой или его
можно наработать А вот если человек не
имеет здесь знаешь такую вещь есть такое
правило железные
[музыка]
точки зрения человека определяется его
положением
если ты стоишь на горе А я внизу твой
взгляд будет другой мой взгляд будет
другой и мы не сойдемся мы видим разные
миры
если я с этой стороны горы от истоки
страны горы мы видим разные миры мы
опять не сойдёмся также я Почему говорю
когда ты майнцет раз переключаешь и
начинаешь думать как собственник ты
начинаешь смотреть по-другому на те же
действия которые ты делал Даже ты хоть
уборщица ты начинаешь думать Моя же
когда ты уборщица ты думаешь каждый день
я должен столько-то квадратных метров
тряпкой провести Там и так далее А когда
ты как собственник ты думаешь не
обязательно каждый день мы важно чтобы
было чисто
важно чтобы было чисто для того чтобы
было чисто не обязательно тряпкой мыть
Может быть там бахилы нужно или может
быть на входе лучше поставить тряпку
Хорошую или там обо что люди могут грязь
оставлять Там и так далее То есть
какие-то такие вещи
меняется взгляд человека Вот недаром
когда говорят например молодой человек
живёт беззаботно раз женился оба первые
изменения его взгляда потом раз у него
ребёнок родился раз по другому начинает
понимаете это Стимул появляется Да вот
если он не столько Стимул это просто ты
физическое перемещение или изменение
твоего статуса меняет твое мышление
просто физическое перемещение вот я же
говорю я буду стоять внизу ты
поднимешься на гору ты физически
перенесся у тебя другой взгляд сразу
с тобой ничего не изменилось просто ты
другое видишь Или ты статус поменял ты
говоришь вот почему есть такой метод
называется 7 шляп когда мозговой штурм
когда принимает решение одевает шляпа на
шляпы пишут на одной штапе пишет он
пессимист на другой штат пишет оптимист
а третий шляпе пишет рационально Ну
рационалист значит четвёртый паниёр на
пятой риск рисковик Ну боится и всё И
вот мы одели шляпы У меня написано э там
оптимист я даются идею Я говорю Это идея
классная вот это вот это вот потому что
моя роль потом мы шляпы меняемся я
понимаю шляпу
рисковика Я говорю я уже обязан думать
по-другому Я говорю вы знаете а на самом
деле в этом есть вот такие туристы
какие-то такие-то такие-то такие-то
риски и самое удивительно что когда люди
начинают меня шляпы они действительно
начинают по-другому мыслить
начинает по-другому мыслить по той же
самой теме смотрите как устроен этот мир
этот мир вообще устроен таким образом я
верю
что одна из теории что
мультивариантность Вселенной Вселенной
вариант Вселенной выбор того варианта
мира или Вселенной которая с тобой
случится зависит от того куда
Направляешь Внимание Внимание это такой
кран которым подключены два шланга один
шланг это ваше время Второй шланг вашей
энергии вот куда вы направляете ваш кран
туда льется ваше время и ваша энергия А
куда
льется ваше время и энергия то
расцветает
того становится много так вот когда вы
начинаете думать только позитивном
позитивного в вашей жизни становится
больше
и интересно
это может быть из-за того что
действительно больше а может быть из-за
того что ты замечаешь этого больше
например когда ты голодаешь на голодовке
ты едешь видишь рекламу только
Макдональдса везде где-то что-то жарят
везде запах жареной картошки все везде
столько и люди только и делают Что едят
Почему Потому что ты начинаешь замечать
только то что ты хочешь
вот также мир устроен когда ты одеваешь
шляпу здесь написано Ты должен замечать
только положительные вещи и ты
действительно в этом проекте видишь
только положительно потом ты одеваешь
шляпу где ты должен видеть только риски
ты начинаешь риски когда ты начинаешь
направлять внимание на риски ты
начинаешь копать и выяснять что там
оказывается риск А еще такое еще такой
До этого ты думал там два три риска
когда начинаешь
уделять этому внимание выяснять десятки
этих рисков на этом построен именно
фокус вот этого приема 7 шляп мозговую
сторону под названием Попробуйте
применить можно не сильно сделать Можно
опять можно три но факт то что я говорю
что изменения точки зрения изменения
статуса меняет твою точку зрения поэтому
Где бы вы не работали в найме или
домработницы и так далее особенно в
найме У вас есть бесплатная лаборатория
компания которая работает каждый день
что-то производит зарабатывает деньги
собственниками и так далее А вы теперь
Представьте что вы собственник и
посмотрите как ваши коллеги что делать
правильно что неправильно Как вы им
сказали правильно действовать и так
далее вы по-другому все будете
воспринимать
Можно вопрос Вот у меня девочка
управляющий директор ресторана находясь
с нами открыла для себя точку доставки
еды И у нее не получилось у нее был
обратная связь к теперь я вас поняла что
это такое Я теперь на все смотрю
по-другому но у нее не получилось это
как она не предприниматель она просто не
туда зашла вот смотрите с точки зрения
это такой вечный спор
предприниматель Это от рождения либо им
можно стать
я к этому покажу таким образом смотрите
существует 20% людей которые никогда не
станут предпринимателями как бы вы их не
обучили также как существуют 20% людей
которые никогда не научатся играть на
пианино как бы вы их не учили у них
просто
нет каких-то нейронов которые отвечают
заставляющих должно быть 20 процентов
которые никогда не научится не смогут
петь 20%, которые никогда не смогут
играть на пианино 20 процентов которые
никогда не смогут кататься на лыжах и
так далее и 20%, которые никогда не
смогут писать предпринимателем Так у нас
остается 80 процентов дальше
из 80 процентов 60 процентов это те люди
которые могут если брать она за аналога
пианино которые могут научиться играть
на пианино чтобы удивлять своих Друзей и
родственников
Ну и иногда немного зарабатывать но
достаточно чтобы прокормить только себя
то есть в ресторане где-то спеть еще
где-то на вечеринке с 5 и так далее Вот
это 60 процентов предприниматель тоже те
люди которые могут себя прокормить Но не
более того открыл киоск продаешь
сигареты там еще что-то там это ну все
остается 20 процентов из этих оставшихся
20 процентов 19 процентов это те люди
которые могут создать крупный бизнес и
стать предпринимателями если брать
аналогию с это с музыкантами это те люди
которым могут зарабатывать деньги на
концертах на большие концертах собирать
публики залы и так далее Это крупные и у
нас один процент предпринимателей это те
которые могут стать лауреатами
международных премий это знаменитые уже
такие артисты которые не столько деньги
зарабатывают А уже становится величинами
как
это у нас есть же такие Марат би
сингалею Да там России был
крутой
и вот смотрите один процент это те люди
которые
предпринимательству уже относится не как
способы зарабатывания денег а это уже
просто создатели создатели как илон Маск
бил здесь и так далее они не оперируют в
рамках денег в понятиях денег Они
оперируют совсем другими понятиями и вот
я вижу вот таким образом 20 процентов
которые никогда не смогут 60 процентов
могут прокормить только себя 19
процентов которые могут собирать залы
или зарабатывать большие деньги один
процент который выходит уже за пределы
Денег которые уже оперируются всеми
другими понятиями таким образом
видите вроде бы как естественно один
процент это те люди которые от рождения
у них и таланты и способности и все и
плюс правильная страна которую они
родились потому что возьмем простой
пример поле Если вы возьмете семя
бросьте в камни она не прорастет
Какое бы крутое семя не было Так ведь
поэтому семени одного мало значит берете
почву Если вы супер богатую почву
положите плохое семя оно прорастет но но
не так
а если вы возьмете супер почву супер
семя но не дадите солнце или воду опять
результата нет то есть понимаете поэтому
для того чтобы попасть в один процент
предпринимателей должно быть у тебя и
почва то есть
страна в которой ты родился
богатый на возможности второе от
рождения у тебя генетика таланты все
должно быть на месте 2 это среда то есть
это солнечный свет который это Я
сравниваю со средой которая поливается
там внимание людей
родственников и так далее признание и
так далее плюс вода там вспомогательным
микроэлементы это те люди которые
коллектив командой и так далее когда она
Все сходится ты уходишь один процент Я
поэтому говорю что большие состояния это
результат везения
это в основном результат везения Ну вот
19 процентов это это вот тоже нужно от
рождения иметь способности но
трудно выбиться в один процент но 60
процентов это основная масса Малый
средний бизнес это вот эти 60 процентов
Давайте теперь мы поговорим о ментальных
ограничениях
мы уже частично затронули эту тему
ментальное ограничение они на самом деле
существуют у всех сегодня классно Зарина
уже сказала Как преодолеть вот я говорил
за счет детства
за счет того что дедушка и доверял она
привыкла расти в условиях доверия
соответственно она Доверие порождает
порождает уверенность уверенность
порождает смелость и она предпринимала
что-то ставила цели достигала за счет
страсти желание этого достичь но она это
не использовала страх страха она боялась
[музыка]
а после у него появился еще один
инструмент который она может себе
использовать для достижения целей это
страх поэтому она вот сейчас решила
взять вторую дозу
прыжок с парашютом в Дубае над пальмой
я не прыгал и для меня это действительно
страшно в прошлом году когда мы пошли на
Килиманджаро Мне тоже было страшно я еще
мог куда мы идем куда еще у нас в мае
стоит поход в базовый лагеря Эвереста
там тоже 5600 если Килиманджаро 5.895
базовый лагерь 5.600 Мы туда тоже Идём Я
сам не знаю зачем я это делаю но
инстинктивно понимаю что нужно это
делать для того чтобы как раз-таки всё
время иметь Вот это топливо
и Давайте поговорим по поводу наших
ментальных ограничений Скажите три вещи
которые вам лично мешают в жизни мешают
Да ограничивают мешают я совсем недавно
принял для себя решение что как раз таки
вот нашёл вот эти ограничения и начал с
ними прорабатывать их и выходить на
новый уровень
в начале января мы с семьей отдыхали на
могилах неделю и первый 10 дней мы были
первые четыре дня я просто спал ничего
не делал потому что за год настолько
истощился и просто хотелось отдохнуть
потом я ходил и размышлял что я делаю
Так что делаю не так и я понимал что
внутри у меня есть какое-то желание идти
дальше но я не понимал что меня
сдерживает
и долго на эту тему размышлял потом
принял решение Я исходил из тех
возможностей которые у меня есть и
смотрю на свой блог то что я веду снимаю
и я понял что
окружение которое я вокруг себя
образовываю оно очень сильно влияет на
мое ментальное состояние и Принятие
решения в моем жизненном пути и я
принимаю там точку зрения Иногда ты
сидишь обсуждаешься и примерно
плюс-минус вы одинаковые нет такого что
в моем окружении кто-то на 10 голов выше
меняли 20 голов выше меня а я там типа
ниже и я понял о чём вы говорили Если ты
находишься в комнате который ты сам
умный Ты значит не в той комнате и я
начал задаваться вопросами А в той или Я
в комнате в том или окружении то ли я
делаю чтобы выйти на новый уровень вот
спросите у любого предпринимателя Кто
там молодого в Казахстане все Да и не
только в Казахстане Все говорят я буду
Миро компании Я буду работать на
международном рынке но при этом мы не
делаем тех конкретных шагов чтобы выйти
на международный рынок и я принял
решение поехать в Дубай я как только
поступила вот эта идея Я понимаю что
нужно что-то менять прилетает приложение
с Дубая чтобы снять выпуск мы снимаем
выпуск одним предпринимателем и я понял
что их его мои цет как он думает он
думает иначе никак Я потому что у него
там четыре филиала в разных странах
компания достаточно большая они
занимаются недвижимостью и я понял мне
нужно искать подобных людей чтобы
расширить свои рамки и за две недели мы
провели я провел 12 интервью я проводил
интервью Почему для меня это стало
ключом я провожу интервью когда ты
проводишь интервью человек более
открытый и больше информации тебе дает
нежели Ты просто делаешь встречу и
хочешь с ним побеседовать когда ты
беседу 30-40 минут и ты там можешь он
задает вопрос Ты задаешь вопрос А когда
ты берёшь интервью у тебя есть
возможность полностью раскрыть и понять
я я нашел этот инструмент я провел куча
встреч там у меня в интервью выйдет вот
скоро Улугбек максумов мой Тезка он
занимается
этот
бронемашинами он поставляет по всему
миру и там огромная компания огромные
обороты вид там разные Ребята с разных
сфер достаточно крупные достаточно
большие для меня и для меня вот я я
сейчас считаю на сегодняшний день
сегодняшнем состоянии что до этого была
моментальная тюрьма А когда я вот начал
предпринимать какие-то действия чтобы
вырваться из нее И вот произошел взрыв
То есть ты считаешь что первое
ограничение которое тебя сдерживала это
среда среда дальше потом
еще один момент расскажу мы снимали
тиктокером Я считаю что это была просто
мне на самом деле в жизни очень сильно
везет вот я не знаю как это как это
заметить какой-то алгоритм бывает очень
часто везет мы снимаем с тиктокером 18
миллионов аудитории Я не знаю зачем
начал снимать потому что я снимаю в
основном предприниматель мне поступил
запросик Ну раз поступил Давай снимем мы
снимаем разговариваем три часа а он
продвигает компанию это биржа
криптобиржа она очень крупная в Европе
они вышли на рынок Дубай и он их
продвигает занимается маркетингом
продвижением и мы снимали у них на вилле
на в офисе и он говорит Давайте сделаем
экскурсию по офису Мы заходим делаем
экскурсию по офису и там сидел Вот сам
основатель этот виллы этой невила
криптобиржи Давай если познакомлю я
говорю давай Он выходит оказалось то что
он русскоговорящий с Узбекистана
мы с ним начинаем разговаривать Он мне
говорит я в 9 лет уехал в Швейцарию и
всю жизнь там прожил и потом мы с
партнёром там с Европы запустили
криптобиржу и капитализация на самом
высоком уровне была миллиард долларов и
выходит за ним локол ну местные жители
араб выходит за ним местные житель и А я
приехал на мустанге я снял Мустанг
шестьдесят пятого года просто невероятно
красивый и он стоял на парковке
мой араб попрощался со всеми выходит на
улицу увидел мой Мустанг возвращается
обратно в дом а мы стоим с ребятами
общаюсь и он говорит подходит под этому
тиктокеру говорит Какой у тебя классный
Мустанг и показывает фотки коллекции
своего Мустанга Я говорю это мой Мустанг
вот этот рядом Фархат узбек он говорит
Ты знаешь кто это я говорю Нет Он
говорит он строит Lamborghini City в
Дубае Я говорю Да ты что помимо этого он
имеет владеет правами Marvel DC Warner
Brothers И еще какой-то я на него смотрю
Давай с тобой интервью запишу и ему
цепляют петличку А у меня английский я
пытаюсь с ним говорить я ему задаю
вопрос Он говорит Да ладно приезжай ко
мне завтра я такой Давай сегодня
он говорит поехали я говорю через час
времени мы приезжаем к нему и мне тогда
просто голову снесло я захожу к нему у
него маленькие бутик он комиксы одно из
направлений Мы заходим туда там сейф
раздвига он пускает только звезд чтобы
понимали к нему приезжали звезды с
Марвел Тор вот эти Бэтмен кто актеры Мы
заходим туда и он показывает комиксы от
10 тысяч долларов Он коллекционирует
комикс 35 лет до 5 миллионов 300 тысяч
долларов комикс и я сижу вот так там
есть кадр Я так сижу и голову блин Что
происходит Что такое и он начинает
рассказывать о своей жизни он говорит он
оказывается потом в каком-то колени
пророка его семья его семья на этот в
Дубае живет 600 лет его дед двоюродный
брат или троюродный брат туман и он это
все рассказал мне Голова просто
квадратная если сижу разговариваю и он
говорит мне
просто Следуй за мечтой нету ограничения
нету рамок и на тот момент мне просто
голова взорвалась я понял то что рамки
мы сами себе выставляем и иногда среда
может так сильно влиять на что мы просто
не неосознанно можем ставить себе
маленькие стеклянные потолки вот крутая
история крутая история Так у вас какие
ментальные ограничения
по традиции Ну ограничение со страхом вы
все знаете как я его преодолела сейчас
нет Его что классно это ощущение такое
Свободы Когда ты можешь делать то что
хочешь планировать рисковать в общем-то
классно сейчас в данное время у меня
есть такой затык это ограничение
развития своего личного бренда Я всегда
думала зачем это нужно ходить с
Инстаграм снимать себя вообще кому нужно
меня смотреть или что я могу так
говорить И вот сейчас я на пути к этому
чтобы от этого избавиться немного и
начать что-то вот в камеру так говорить
или делать но самый главный мой закон
вот как Улугбек сказал что он Везучий У
меня тоже такое есть иногда ощущение что
я то что я хочу всегда происходит 2
недели назад У меня появилась мысль Вот
бы моргоем колеевич позвал меня на
фантаст
А я две недели назад чувствую Меня тянет
позвать за Арину на подкат блин вы
Будьте осторожны за своими желаниями
вы безответственно желаете А мне
исполнять их А у меня была мысль когда
же могла колеч меня позовёт я знал что
позовёт нас задумка и даже
не честно я я тот человек который не
слежу за соцсетями Я не знаю знаменитых
людей Мой муж очень следит за всем я не
знаю но я практически не слежу И я очень
редко смотрю Подкасты сказать не смотрел
на 2 недели не Вот это я захотела и вот
результат Да такое то есть да я поняла А
вообще наверное с момента как я
университет Закончила я поняла одно
правило я его назвала закон термостата в
чём он заключается А когда закончила
такую университет у меня первая зарпла
было 70 тысяч тенге я на это жила потом
90 тысяч тенге 30 тысяч тенге откладывал
на магистратуру чтобы обучиться
остальное как-то там что-то делала
нормально и вот я поняла одну вещь Что
закон термостата имеет ввиду вот я себе
поставила цель допустим сначала 150
тысяч хочу 500 тысяч там 10 тысяч
долларов и так далее ты наращиваешь вот
эту планку себе и
человек Допустим если ему скажет
Заработай миллион и он скажет да Ну как
заработать что на что я его потрачу это
нереально он не заработает этот миллион
а термостат Это имеется в виду
переключить своё сознание на новый
уровень То есть если человек знает На
что он потратит эти деньги Если он знает
как их заработать если он верит что он
достоин заработать этих денег то они у
него по-любому придут то есть закон
термостат именно в том чтобы
изучать периодически свое сознание и
свой уровень выше выше и тогда Вселенная
Она всегда дает то что мы хотим просто
вот действительно желать мечты ставить
цели ставить и они всегда исполняются и
по сути здесь Смысл в том что люди
которые может быть недостаточно
зарабатывать они просто сами себе
поставили
вот эту планку и считать чтобы что чтобы
заработать больше нужно быть там не знаю
мошенником Или суперумным или супер
крутым это невозможно Хотя все возможно
ограничение были страх второе ты по
социальным сетям эти ограничения 3 это
вот планка
но у меня самая главная мой этот
ограничение до сих пор есть что я плохое
управление Казалось бы звучит странно да
Там не все те работы 2000 человек но я
по сей день уверена что я плохой
управленец я синдром самозванца это
такой общеизвестный синдром Ну да я знаю
но я не думаю что синдром Но на самом
деле если так взять у меня там за 5 лет
уже сегодня сидит третий генеральный
директор и всё равно получается не так
как я хочу и человек не видит картину
как мне надо Ну вот именно управлять
если например в ресторане начинается
управляющего директор там до конца или
там сварки лапши вверх Я знаю абсолютно
всё я эти все процессы выстраиваю А
здесь у меня как-то не получается и
двигаюсь по-другому делаю по-другому Я
понимаю что всё не так и вот в офисе в
офисе стопами работа идёт совершенно
по-другому И у меня всё время кажется
вот этот вот постоянный затык я делаю её
не так сначала я очень много себе там
ругала обвиняла Там постоянно какие-то
были Сейчас я просто стала принимать всё
как есть или есть момент может быть у
меня было тоже должна ему училась нам
наверное на входе я не тех людей не
понимаю не так выбираю Мне казалось этот
ещё моя Лень я не люблю там вот эти вот
процессы финансов Вот это всё остальное
дое- двигаюсь и двигаюсь Я хочу чтобы
сзади там была сильная команда которая
всё успевает команда во-первых не
успевает во-вторых вот это вот я
пыталась всё время делегировать а отдать
то что я плохо знаю А сейчас я понимаю
что в любом случае нужно погружаться Да
и я должна всё тебе вот эти
управленческие навыки в любом случае
постоянно развивать и Чем я сейчас
занимаюсь но я чётко понимаю Мне это
настолько Не нравится не настолько
некомфортно Я не могу сидеть целый день
на работе Вот абсолютно мне сложно даёт
я вот пока вот это вот это не смогла в
себе побороть абсолютно
первый ты считаешь что ты хороший
управленец
второе ты мне хочешь заниматься
рутинными делами
третье что тебе мешает тебе является
заниматься вообще базовой операционной
она в первую очередь это мой
перфекционизм мне всегда хотелось
сделать все идеально тут я тоже может
быть
все время люди каждый день это очень
сильно мешает и ограничивает и когда Тем
более ты думаешь что ты сам делаешь
лучше и как раз второе вытекающий это
чувство контроля всегда любил все
контролировать и я понял что надо
все-таки не контролировать отдавать
свободу Да своим людям своей команде
чтобы они тоже что-то делали и конечно
же это окружение как клубы тоже сказал
потому что пока я не был в том окружении
в котором я хочу быть я реально не рос и
даже будучи там Чечне потом даже в
Москве даже приезд сюда вот это желание
найти свое окружение нужное окружение
которое вы создали да в котором я сейчас
нахожусь это прям реально дает рост То
есть я сейчас работа реально Над тем над
своим перфекционизмом Как вы говорили
эффективно несовершенство Вот это прям
четко вы сказали что любой продукт ты
сам может быть не совершенен но это не
значит что ты можешь ведь неэффективным
это факт и также контроль я сейчас
делегирую я также кстати агентство
маркетинга открыл вместе со своей
супругой сейчас кстати Зарина будем
раскручивать И кстати еще один момент
четвёртый пункт - это миссия отсутствие
миссии Да вот и когда пока я не нашёл
свою миссию я слишком расфокусирована
работал в разных областях например когда
я приехал сюда Я налаживал торговые
отношения между Россией и Казахстаном
там автомобили запчасти всё это ну меня
это не нравилось я зарабатывал
но потом всегда во мне было желание
приносить пользу людям но никогда не
понимал чётко как это делать но
благодаря опять-таки окружению могла
колевичу я Ну вот именно ограничения
предпринимателей то что мы себя не
обесцениваем недооцениваем даже возьмем
Зарину свои компетенции свои возможности
и как раз именно личный бренд на
сегодняшний очень мощный инструмент и на
него нужно смотреть как на инструмент и
понимать что благодаря нему тоже может
вырасти любой Эксперт любой
предприниматель И когда я понял что
многие предприниматели имеют очень
большие компетенции экспертность и в
тоже но не спозиционирует себя в
социальных сетях но в то же время заняли
ребят которые не имея особых компетенций
очень мощно себя позиционирует и
раскрутили и зарабатывают очень много не
захотелось вот какой-то баланс создать я
реально открыл компанию специально
агентство маркетинг
она до сих пор себя считает не
хорошим неэффективным
руководителем управленцем но при этом 46
ресторанов еще 10 строят вот пожалуйста
даже должным образом как себя
позиционировать вот этот скачок сделать
на новый уровень выйти предпринимателю
очень сложно с этим не все нормально с
личным брендом с экспертность Это я всё
со всем этим работаю А вот именно вот
как управление Я считаю что
опять-таки не обязательно быть прям
управленцем можно взять управляться но
самому не управлять Я например тоже не
люблю опрессонкое вообще управлять я
понимаю как двигать проекты как
развивать как Команду команду создавать
но сам операционка я не занимаюсь
абсолютно я вышла Я делегировала всё что
нужно делегировать а делать только то
что я могу сделать Я всё всё остальное
отдала
а по вашему вопросу А у вас День
директор который делает
это то что я жду от него не то что я
хочу недавно слушала от hr-капитал
тренинг и он там говорит что говорите
своим сотрудникам результат труда
который вы от них ждете потому что вы
отдельный человек Он отдельный и у него
могут быть свои мысли о понимании того
что есть хорошо то есть что значит вести
правильно бизнес и достичь Успеха у вас
свое видение но вы можете там допустим
год полгода потратить и если ему
получается не донести что вы от него
ждете он может пойти по другому а по
итогу вы скажете ты не сделал так как
надо а он скажет нет я сделал это вы
Представьте задачи да то есть
интересная вещь что люди Они не могут Ну
как бы они все разные и когда он там
говорит что когда человек ставит
конкретное измеримые цели и Что является
по факту результатом его труда тогда
сотрудники лучше ориентируются понимают
что у меня наверное немножко отношение к
команде такое Я считаю что мы сидим на
одном корабле и все должны в одну
сторону смотреть если у меня любой
сотрудник особенно топы начинает якорить
и ставить моё решение под сомнение даже
самое безумное то вот как-то получается
Вселенная Так распорязаешь распоряжается
что человек - это вылетает из команды
неважно Там какой Вам компетенции сильно
профессионал бы не был вот я считаю что
вот мы должны все смотреть в одну
сторону Если кто-то начал якорить всё э
бизнес приостанавливается может быть
поэтому у меня вот такой момент
получается что я больше вопрос к миссии
Я считаю если чётко не обозначена
миссией в принципе в компании всё всё
смотрите здесь вот просто такое Давайте
вот по порядку пойдём ну прежде всего
вопрос перфекционизма я в своё время
тоже был перфекционистом я пытался всё
делать идеально во всём хотел порядок но
потом пришёл понимаете такого Ну что
жизнь она в жизни никогда порядка не
будет до конца э жизненно на самом деле
всегда у нас между порядками хаосом
соответственно Ты должен пустить свою
жизнь немножко хаос и когда я начал
смотреть графики эффективности Я понял
что первые 75-80 процентов усилий
которые ты делаешь они эффективны А
дальше уже докручивания до докручивания
дошлифовывания оно неэффективно
получается ты дошлифовываешь затраты
энергии внимание столько же уходит А
выхлоп Меньше меньше более того в каждой
технологии говорится один из видов
потерь называется это излишняя обработка
когда ты клиенту даешь продукт больше
чем он ожидает то есть
перенавороченный продукт поэтому я в то
же время думал а как же делать чтобы
продукт был идеальный я для себя понял
что я должен делать 75 процентов
остальное должна делать команды я должен
делегировать потому что их цена их
времени цена их внимание дешевле
соответственно дошлифовка более дешевыми
ресурсами дает больше
теперь то что касается
везения Вот
ты поднял Зарина знаете американцы
проводили такое исследование они собрали
людей которые считали себя везунчиками и
собрали людей которые не считались
везунчиками 500 человек тех 500 человек
тех и далее газету
и сказали
посчитать сколько многодетным листе слов
команда везунчиков
самый лучший справился за две минуты
в среднем они все справились где-то в
районе 4-5 минут
команда которая себя считала невезучими
они в среднем справлялись за 17-18 минут
почти в 4-5 раз хуже
секрет оказался Знаете в чем
газета открываешь вторую страницу на
второй странице большими буквами было
написано дальше Не считайте в этой
странице 563 слова
везунчики читали эту надпись а те
которые были
Они продолжали считать слово слова
представляете вот это феномен самое
интересное самое интересное
из не везунчиков были люди которые
заметили эту надпись
но они не решились пойти
сказать и чтобы улучшить результат не
везунчиков они что делали исследователь
написали дальше Не считайте в этой
странице 563 слова Идите и скажите
своими экзаменаторами
и после этого часть не везунчиков
улучшила свои результаты
вы представляете разница Вот видите как
внимание работает когда у тебя внимание
на правильно ты везунчик Ты замечаешь в
этом мире все что в твою пользу и из-за
этого они укрепляются в ощущении что они
везунчики и это привносит им еще больше
удачи Потому что они видят больше
возможностей они в каждом событии видят
возможность Вот ты приехал к тиктокеру
вначале брал интервью другого Потом
возьму брал интервью ты кто раз
познакомился с хозяином биржи раз э по
пути ещё познакомилась видишь с каждым
событием ты видишь возможности в каждом
Назарбаев пришёл Ты заодно сразу и
пассадорами попросил стать и так далее
таким образом
везунчики это американский исследователи
исследователи доказали что везунчики это
не особо не так не какие-то другие люди
это люди с особым
пониманием или ощущениям что им везет
потому что они самого начала с детства
видать у них настроился фокус только на
положительно на том что именно им везет
и из-за этого реально постоянно везет
даже вот простой пример из газеты не
везунчики считали слова а везунчики
посмотрели прочитали что в этой газете
столько слов прошли сказали экзаменатор
вот интересно Это то что касается вот
перфекционизм Я сказал то что касательно
везение теперь то что касается
делегирования интересная вещь Дело в том
что
многие люди неправильно понимают что
нужно делегировать
так вот делегировать нужно то в чем вы
хорошо разбираетесь
нельзя делегировать в том что ты не
разбираешься Потому что когда ты
делегируешь то что в чем-то не
разбираешься ты не можешь понять
Насколько качественно Этот человек
выполняет свою работу раз а во-вторых ты
не можешь повлиять на его работу потому
что не знаешь как она должна выполняться
поэтому смотрите Смысл делегирования
всегда заключается в том чтобы отдать от
себя рутину то в чем ты уже идеально
разбираешься а самой заняться более
сложными более важными делами
вот я привожу частный пример когда вот
например идут гости Я специалист по
приготовлению плова а гостям надо дать
бешбармак потому что это казахи
Соответственно что делегировать плов или
бешбармак большинство говорят бешбармак
Потому что ты в нем не разбираешься Я
говорю наоборот надо делегировать плов а
саму готовить бешбармак Потому что ты
поддаешь максимальную ответственно а
приготовление плова ты не упустишь
потому что ты краем глаза будешь видеть
там воды долей То есть ты делегируешь то
что от тебя требует минимального участия
и контроля Потому что ты уже знаешь воды
долей огонь добавь
сконцентри на приготовление бешбармака
сам морковки побольше Положи Ты спокойно
контролируешь
и вот Представьте если плов не получился
Ты знаешь почему не получился
а представьте вы поручили кому-то делать
бешбармак но сами не разбирайтесь в этом
не бешбармак не получился и исполнитель
начинает тебе говорить тесто было не то
Мясо было не то
этот огонь был не тот Казан был не тот
тысяч причины ты не можешь доказать
потому что не разбираешься
поэтому делегировать всегда надо то в
чем ты сам хорошо разбираешься первое
второе что ты можешь легко
контролировать что на контроль чего у
тебя требуется меньше всего внимания Вот
именно то и делегировать а остальное
важное ты должен заниматься всегда
важными делами Представьте что в жизни
это как такой экзамен ты вот сдал это
уже на отлично дальше тоже начать
заниматься другими предметом и таким
образом ты растешь и вот мы сегодня уже
посмотрели и обсудили все темы эта тема
на самом деле предпринимательское
мышление быть предпринимателем такая
Огромная большая тема но
надо на чем-то все равно останавливаться
поэтому я думаю нам уже пора
закругляться с этой темой Я хочу
напомнить нашим телезрителям или
зрителям нашего канала что сейчас гемба
подкаст уже доступен для всех подкаст
площадках Если вы привыкли служить нас в
аудиоформате то пожалуйста любой
аудиоподкастной платформа площадка там
подкаст в iTunes или в этом Play Маркете
любая площадка мы там есть и этот гемба
подкаст будет там тоже присутствует
Поэтому если вы вам нравится
больше слушать они смотреть картинку
Если вы это делаете во время бега спорта
и так далее так далее Пожалуйста
подключайтесь к нам по подкаст сейчас
доступен везде Ну а вам дорогие Наши
гости друзья Я хотел бы пожелать удачи
чтобы у вас все хорошо получалось У вас
уже принципе уже хорошие достижения есть
о чем поговорить был рад с вами
встретиться провести подкаст я уверен
зрителям тоже будет интересно потому что
сегодняшние нашей истории были очень
Живые и очень жизненные
Мне очень понравилось Я надеюсь что
нашим зрителям тоже это понравится и
самое главное цель всех вещей которые я
делаю Это принесение пользы людям
принесение пользы людям через
образование через обучение Я надеюсь
сегодняшний подкаст выполнил эту роль
Спасибо Спасибо
[музыка]